yo guys Greg Alva here John here Kyle
Kyle's here alright spider-man Home
Coming trailer just drop but waiting all
[ __ ] day for this all day
I'm so excited come on finish
downloading finish downloading finish
downloading here we go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
can't prove myself
okay
[Music]
oh wait a minute you guys aren't the
real Avengers
I can tell hope gives it away sweet mics
on right yep listen Tom know we've seen
that before
no that's Kurt probably stops territory
it's creepy though guys are losers
interesting we're coming Avengers
uttering like trials or any movie just
don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
you there's a little gray area I know
school sucks
yes you still with us oh yeah yeah
I know you want to save the world
you never dear here's the spare man
no not nah this is awesome it's true
scene J Lo's body falls to the ground
and stay out of trouble
vote sir forget the flying monster guy
there are people who handle this sort of
thing you can treat me like a kid all
the time but you are a kid this is my
chance to prove myself
what is going on with you I'm sorry I'm
so busy I'm slammed damn cuz I'll kill
you and everybody you blow
[Music]
Wow
oh my god that looks so good Alex Graham
Cooper my my Oh fine all right
well Jill is a nipple - I got some
nipple chills right now definitely I'll
feel that Oh
it's a hard nose happening that's a hard
nipple wow I'm so enthralled I don't
even know if I caught everything I was
just been anticipating this all day I
gotta say that the tone that they were
talking about that John Watts wanted to
get together of really making this feel
like a boy in high school
yeah dealing with that specific age that
he's at being 15 years old and the world
that he's in it's like there's a life he
has in high school and then there's the
life of spider-man and that really does
translate in this trailer yeah it really
does look like they're they're gonna
make it a high school movie about
coming-of-age lessons yeah The Avengers
references or I think are fine in this
tray like I feel like Marvel knows how
to do that in a way where it doesn't get
on my nerves of like the references to
the other Marvel characters what I like
of how they're using Tony Stark is it's
not like you know he has a cameo in
there and they're just ruining it for
you they're really making they're really
showing he's like a supporting active
player in this specific film yeah I'm
glad they're gonna use him like that
it's like 20 how life it hasn't been an
Iron Man for but there's been an age of
Ultron Civil War no Spider Man this is
how Iron Man keeps living on that's
pretty interesting to me
yeah yeah well it seems like they've
learned from Iron Men - yeah it's like
that black widows here and his nick
fury's ventures on the side but like it
seems like yeah it seems like there's a
reason to have Robert Downey jr. well I
mean yet wherever Dungey is more of a
sage character if we watch it again real
quickly let's do that sorry sighs two
minutes but myself
really not necessary for us
[Music]
what are they stealing just money money
is bankrupt
so guys wait a minute you guys aren't
the real Avengers
I can tell hope gives it away great
humor I really like his suit he seems
more like a boy who is like like
mesmerized well the cool [ __ ] he can do
yeah it's not torturous yet there's
definitely a multi-ethnic cast in this
oh yeah absolutely
Michelle is actually in the comics but
very briefly just don't do anything I
would do and definitely don't do
anything I wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you are that's not how come
just grab the chalkboard okay this
really does feel more like a personal
movie about Peter Parker other than
later on in the trailer yeah yeah you
still with us oh yeah I know you want to
save the world
[Music]
No
vulture ventures forget the flying
monster guy there are people who handle
this sort of thing you can treat me like
a kid all the time but you argued this
is my chance to prove myself
what is going on here I'm sorry I'm so
busy up slam I'll kill you and everybody
you blow
[Music]
yeah like oh is it all the spectacled
[ __ ] looks cool the thing that I am
confused on they've done a lot of things
with vulture before but traditionally
vulture is a life sucker like he I have
sex of life honey and I'm not sure how I
feel about like it's mechanical honor
technological yeah it sure look at yeah
we've already done that with goblin with
you know yeah one evenin like ant-man
like the wasp a guy was like it they
have it looks burnt horrible yeah yeah
exactly and I think the one thing I like
about spider-man is he's more often
other than when you're dealing with [ __ ]
but it's usually biological villainy and
it's biological powers and everything's
more biological and I think Marvel
Cinematic Universe is is that they're
very focused on the either mystical or
the mechanical and they're definitely
taking a mechanical approach with the
villain on this one where's the helmet
everything which is not at all yeah he
doesn't wear a helmet is vulture you
know like you we barely get a glimpse of
Michael Keaton actually like doing some
wines in this in this trailer but you
know if you're getting Michael Keaton in
there I know the MCU has a reputation
for not being the greatest with their
villains Michael Keaton though is like
really respected this is like regard is
amazing actor and I really hope they
utilize the fact they got Michael Keaton
to be the vulture which is even more
reason why it's weird that they cover
his face up when he's in his suit well
that's what that's the thing I this
trailer leaves me wondering about
because you know knowing how advertising
works now you know we get a glimpse for
the spectacle and now I'm wondering if
there's gonna be like a trailer 2 that
has a lot more spectacle yeah cuz that's
what I'm saying I liked about this shows
like the last though only the last 30
seconds have a lot of spectacle the
first minute in like 40 something
seconds are rather contained and they
feel like a personal story really from
the perspective of this fifteen-year-old
kid yeah this to me was sort of like
this kind of felt like watching an older
trailer where when they showed me a
piece of spectacle I almost felt like oh
that's probably from the big 3rd act set
piece yeah and most of the time when we
watch these I'm like I'm sure these will
be throughout the film I like the looks
of this trailer and I'm just curious now
as to what its gonna be like any if the
next trailer se is gonna have a lot more
vulture in it or something
I'm filling trailer you know yeah
exactly um so yet but it's definitely
picking my interest you know I'm
definitely excited actively you know
this looks like a coming of a trip oh
there's a spirit about it that just
looks very genuine and exciting and it
looks like it has a distinct Peter
Parker story and a distinct spider-man
story because they're both in school you
know exactly he's in high school and and
Pedro is getting restless about being an
Avenger high school you know like he's
knocking down bank robbers and stuff but
Robert Downey jr. is like hey hey leave
the big [ __ ] to us he's like nah man I
got all these powers and like yeah that
there it seems like they're embracing is
yeah well situation is yeah I really do
I really feel the approach to the
director kept saying you want to take
with this it seems incredibly evident
here that sense of like a Boy Wonder
not Robin but you know like a boy boy
wonder about all this yeah I do like
that they're not focusing as much on his
romantic entanglement oh thank god yeah
yeah so I mean there's a little bit of
you know a little bit of that but it's
not like the focal point especially like
what it was with Amazing Spiderman or
even the Sam Raimi ones like a lot of it
was marriage and well that's an integral
part to his life sure I think it's great
at the first trailers especially I don't
know if the movie will but I think it's
great the trailers not trying to like
show you look at all the characters we
have you know
yeah that's rushing yeah it's and and I
you know part of me kind of hopes that
they'll do a like the lizard was in the
Sam Raimi movies were like Mary Jane's
in the background flights yeah and
finally she had the plot you know and I
would get a really huge kick out of it
all right guys oh yeah it is trailer
finally dropped would you guys think of
it I'm sure you guys loved it too you
can subscribe to the reel rejects John
as reasons to Jerry on instagram and
twitter is a social media manager of
facebook's of blue mouse and real
rejects kyle you can follow him on
twitter periscope instagram at the kyle
Ehrman he is starting up a YouTube
channel watchfully be launching by
January keep an announcer look out for
that and oh my god Spidey Spidey is
coming back bye